joining me here on the rich eisen show
is uh
the host of double cross with blake
griffin that's going to air friday
and saturday march 19th and march 20th
inside
ncaa coverage on true tv and now a
member of
the brooklyn nets blake griffin how are
you blake
i'm doing well how are you i am hanging
in there um
i i just called you by your your new
title not just as a host of a show but
by the uh of the brooklyn nets
and um which one you want to talk about
first blake i'll give you a dealer's
choice
which one do you want to hit first
whatever you want to talk about man your
[ __ ]
it's my [ __ ] well i don't know i mean
i've spoken i've spoken to jeff
ross uh jeffrey ross the great
roastmaster general
who says you work very very well
comedically on the fly
so that's why i kind of wanted to throw
that down like an improv
like this is like an improv like well i
i guess
i mean normally you as you pointed out
it's like who's
who show is it anyway and you pointed
out i guess it's mine but i figured i'd
give you that
well let's let's talk let's talk
basketball first because that's always
that's always uh that's always on the
front of my mind
okay so let's talk some ball first um
before we get to the next part of it um
the pistons part of it i i've honestly
never heard
uh of too many situations like the one
that you were going through i guess
andre drummond
as well in cleveland where is it was it
essentially in detroit where
it was like we we agree that this is
going to be some sort of
end of a relationship and we don't want
to play you
until we know you're gone so you don't
get hurt is that literally the way it
went
in detroit no um no i mean first of all
i have a
a great relationship with with arn't elm
over there who runs runs everything for
them
and have a ton of respect for him they
just came to me and said like hey listen
we're
going in a different direction we we're
like this is a you know
pretty much a full rebuild um i think
this year you know they they'd
kept derrick and derrick rose and i on
and and they wanted us to sort of like
you know training camp mentor
and and help out you know we had so many
young guys so many new guys and they
want us to be there for that and
um you know we did that and and derek
had you know made a decision that he
wanted to you know try to play for a
playoff team and and
you know play more minutes somewhere and
and they honored that and then
aaron came to us um and and sort of sort
of said like hey this is this is where
we're at
um you know you can do whatever you want
um as far as
um you know we're we're gonna sit you
some
um but um you can kind of do whatever
you want and we all felt it was best to
to let these these guys like move
forward and
and you know play these young guys which
they wanted to do and um work something
out that
uh benefited both of us um and and
you know moving on so i'm i'm grateful
to to that that organization aren't
telling them in particular
um for for you know just being a you
know open honest and and
and you know dealing with this like he
did well he's one of the
more legendary former agents or agents
in the league so obviously he's been
there
and and done that in terms of player
relationships and things like that so
so the way that it was termed similar to
what may be playing out with andre
drummond and cleveland just to bring him
up one last time here
that is not the case it was not a
similar situation
for you and what seems to be going on
for him there
uh i honestly i don't know like his
particular situation
right detail but um a little bit
different i believe
okay and so now in terms of working out
my gosh uh the brooklyn nets
blake this is uh talk about an amazing
team that seems to be getting more and
more amazing
how did you wind up with the nets was it
as simple as you're seeing what they're
putting together and you wanted to go
give yourself a best shot at a ring
right now or or were there other teams
that
are in the mix for a championship that
you had a chance to
to hook up with if you wouldn't walk
yeah yeah there was definitely uh
definitely
uh other teams um you know it was a it
wasn't an easy decision by any means but
um
you know i've known i've known katie
james deandre
obviously um and and kai for a long time
and um you know always you always think
about playing with different guys and
um ultimately just made the decision i
thought it was best best for myself um
so i'm excited for the opportunity i
mean obviously they're a great team and
i'm happy to be a part of that
organization and so did any of those
guys reach out to you and
hit you on your phone and was there any
recruiting that went down
uh uh well not until the appropriate
time because that was
tampering um but yeah i spoke to
you well i guess when you when you were
bought out when when the buyout hit you
were free
i mean they were able to hit you up and
start talking to you on that front that
they do that
that's what i mean yeah i talked to i
talked to from from all the teams i
talked to
to several guys so um yeah it was it was
a
it was like i said a tough decision but
um i just just went with what i thought
was best how do you
how do you think it's going to work i
mean what it what is your role i imagine
you've spoken to steve nash already what
is the role that you have
i have i have um you know i think that
they're they're
they need a four um you know and
sometimes they'll play a small ball five
and
um you know i'm i'm there to help
however i can i'm uh
you know i think at this point in my
career i've um
able to sort of fit sort of different
roles um
and and um you know
my whole goal is to to help this team
win like every year but
um obviously you know the teams that are
looking at their their
real real chances to do that so
i was appreciative of all the teams but
i'm looking i'm excited to be a
net of course and um how many teams were
there i don't want to i obviously don't
want to put you in a position to name
names but how many grand total teams
were there
i i like at the at the
sort of end of it i narrowed it down to
four um four teams so
um all four great teams and great
organizations but
you know i keep saying tried to make the
right decision
okay and then before we again move to uh
to double cross with blake griffin
um if i told you when uh you left the
clippers that you'd be teammates with
deandre jordan once again one day but
you'd also be teammates the same time
with arden
durant and kyrie irving you would have
told me what
um when i when i left the club i
honestly i would have been like
anything can happen after happening so
i i i guess i'd be inclined to believe
it
you know anything can happen in this
league so uh
now now we're here so i guess throwing
steve nash on as the coach is the cherry
on top that still that
still wouldn't phase you no i still
believe it i'd still believe it i'd
still believe uh
i mean just just keep throwing more i
was that's no it's just insane though it
really is when you put it all together
blake
it really is in all seriousness it's
it's it
it um that just seems like it would
never happen um
especially because at the time like
everybody's in different spots
of course you mean so far first coming
together whereas katie and kyrie and
then you know james and
um you know steve coming in the summer
it it uh
yeah it is it is it is nuts i was i was
mostly kidding but
um but at the same time that is
that is this league that we're in today
um you know you see
see crazy stuff happen i've got blake
griffin here on the rich eisen show
let's talk double cross with blake
griffin it's it's
uh going to air on true tv at a
major time during ncaa coverage on the
friday and saturday of the first weekend
of the ncaa tournament it's a prank show
are you pranking just regular good
old-fashioned uh
americans or anybody that we know of
here blake
mostly for the vote for from what i know
most people were americans
um what we did with this is uh we you
know we keep things right here in
america
um what we did is is we took people who
are normally the ones pranking their
friends significant others whoever it
was
right and we sort of flipped the script
on them we we said like hey do you want
to prank somebody like are you a good
prankster and they're like yes i prank
this person all the time
we went to the other person was like hey
your friend's going to prank
prank you do you want to get him back
and that's the idea the show
is sort of a prank within a prank um
and and flipping the script on people
who are uh always doing the pranking so
it allows for you know us to to cover
everything a little bit better because
everybody thinks they're in on the prank
and uh it turned out it was it was a lot
of fun we shot it really quickly
um and and not really quickly but we
shot it we were able to shoot it in a
condensed amount of time and
um get everything we wanted who's what's
the best prank you've ever pulled off
on anybody that we might know of in the
environment
in the nba yeah um you kind of have to
be careful
you can't go too far with nba pranks you
know just a bunch of that
and and everybody has sort of unlimited
resources to get you back
so you you kind of you kind of have to
like
you know make sure you're really you're
really going for i pranked a lot of my
friends
most of which i would probably can't
share on this okay
so you have to make sure that you prank
somebody with not nba
resources to hose you back that's why
that's why everybody pranks the rookies
and they put peanuts in their car and
they can do all this stuff um just
because they're not you know
they haven't figured out the ends and
the outs and and how to get people back
or
where they're scared no i i have i
wasn't joking
at the beginning of this conversation
blake that jeffrey ross i've known him
almost 20 years and um
for his uh his show where he was
uh roasting history um there was like a
there was like a premier pre-covet
and you were there i mean obviously you
stand out in a crowd blake and
i i said to him like what's blake
griffin doing here and he literally said
he's one of the funniest guys i know
and said that you could have a career in
comedy if you so chose to do it
is that what you'd want to do would you
want to do something like that
blake um i don't i don't think i'm
necessarily going to do comedy
my whole thing is like i don't want to i
i i'm friends with jeff as well and i
have other friends who do comedy and i
i've been such a big fan for a long time
i don't want to
skip these steps i know how hard it is
to get to where
guys like jeff ross are and they've gone
and bombed in rooms
and done open mics and you know they've
they've really
earned everything to get there so what i
sort of try to focus on is like doing
projects like this where i get to give
you know our actors that were in on on
everything a platform to show their
talent or you know i have a
charity event every year that's a
stand-up charity event and um i get to
invite
six comedians who i think are really
funny and give them a platform to to do
comedy um
so that's sort of my whole stance when
it comes to comedy is i don't want to
take time away from somebody else
i want to try to give them the give them
the platform to to reach more people or
to get their stuff out there
are you thinking about your post-playing
career platform already i mean is that
what something like this is about
blake i mean you're still here um i mean
you know what yeah i mean since
honestly since i came in i think they've
hardly they they
hit us over the head so much when we
came in it's like prepare for retirement
now the average career is four years so
early on i mean even like my draft class
i remember like talking to other guys
and like everybody
had started you know doing this so long
ago you know
and i have as well um and i think it's
so smart because you
just never know but also at the same
time there's there's no harm in
um you know getting into something that
you like and and
um you know showing people that hey i'm
passionate about this this isn't just
like
oh i'm retired i have to do something
now um so so that's sort of
sort of sort of the approach before i
let you go um and as i know you're
talking to more people again about your
show double cross with blake griffin
did you watch the nba slam dunk
competition
blake and how does somebody who's jumped
over a car
for such a thing view the competition
these days
uh i did watch i thought i mean i
thought like to me cassie stanley's
first dunk was yeah
like i don't know how somebody gave him
an eight
i i don't even i mean i i don't know how
he got
one of the lowest scores uh on that dunk
but like you know it's up to the judges
i i
am obviously biased and i have a soft
spot for guys that are in the dung
contest because it's not
easy and you know you miss a dunk and
then you start to panic and you're like
i gotta just get something down
um i thought i thought it was good i
thought it was fun to watch i mean they
didn't quite have the theatrics that
we've seen before
um but i also don't know that they were
necessarily allowed to do all that um
because of given you know the the
climate that we're in and and
also it was at halftime like well they
they
they should have i think they should
have done it differently
but i mean i agree with you i think
cassius stanley is like all right i'm
going to come out i'm going to make an
impact
and then he nailed it i mean then he
nailed it and then got hosed i think
that got in his head
the rest of the the rest of the
competition and then
missing missing like i think he missed
like his first couple attempts on a
second dunk
and that i think that hurts too because
you like i said you get flustered but
the the thing is like afterwards you
know like years later when they show
this dunk contest they're not going to
show all the misses
you know what i mean so just keep going
until you get that one dunk that you did
and not move to a new one
blake um congrats on double cross with
blake griffin everyone should check it
out uh
on friday march 19th saturday march 20th
inside ncaa
on uh true tv i appreciate it blake
let's uh let's do this a little bit more
often if you don't mind and catch up
with you down the road as you
no doubt hit play off basketball this
year congrats on that absolutely
appreciate it thank you
you bet that's blake griffin at blake
griffin 23 on both twitter and instagram
right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here